[Music]
he
like this go
like you have to move your body out of
the
way then in this hip has to pull out of
technique back hold up
gra
your always
[Music]
relax hitting the target is resisting so
if I if I pushing from this angle here
that's a resisting on his MK okay I want
his head to do a loop and and I'm going
to get on the other side of his head you
understand that so his head does a loop
and then I'm going to go on that
side don't come in here and then push
him you just change in the
gometry look for how I'm going on the
other side of this head boom
[Music]
then you can work your body so in spine
up
in contract in up
in so in up
in in
[Applause]
up contract expand
contract hey
you're missing a lot
contract okay so here's good here some
of you not so good but others okay but
then here you're doing an an expanding
move okay look your arms you're going
down oh your Center
pulls your arms down just like your
Center lifts your arms up in the first
part this the middle part so boom my
Center does it by P extending my spine
then I move
in extend don't lift with your deltoid
your
spine don't let it isolate so
relax so that the deltoid doesn't
Bight okay let's
go you feel that deadness come
in and you feel your delto
I didn't he is my throat too okay so you
don't want to stay here and
push I'm going to try and get your head
to spin
[Music]
very much
down the usual one is here and then
down it's going to go
right from
here down
don't T
come
down
okay down
TR to notice my ton angle in
timing doesn't go back there see just
goes out to the
side hey he's trying to hold my hand so
I contract my
Center
okay contract now it's under me then I
align my
side I organize one side of my
body here then organize that side
then it can go
down then all I got to
do is move myself out of the way spread
my feet and the Hand lowers all the
way you guys see
that
TR oh
[Music]
okay both techniques
let's
shoot after
hi e
track in
terrible terrible get your Center up
Center
up foot comes
through organize your butt see sticking
your butt out leg through then
back leg through and back
organized
see the second hand
[Music]
all